Pasó menos de un año del 11-S
y yo estaba en el Chicago Tribune
escribiendo sobre tiroteos y asesinatos,
y eso me hacía sentir
bastante oscuro y deprimido.
En la universidad había hecho activismo
así que decidí ayudar a un grupo local
a colgar llamadores contra la experimentación con animales.
Pensé que sería una forma segura
de hacer algo positivo,
pero, claro, tuvimos la peor suerte de la historia,
y nos arrestaron a todos.
La policía tomó esta foto borrosa de mí
sosteniendo folletos como evidencia.
Mis cargos fueron desestimados,
pero unas semanas más tarde,
dos agentes del FBI llamaron a mi puerta,
y me dijeron que si no les ayudaba
espiando a grupos de protesta,
me pondrían en una lista de terroristas nacionales.
Me encantaría decirles que ni me inmuté,
pero estaba aterrado,
y cuando se me pasó el miedo,
me obsesioné con averiguar
cómo fue que ocurrió esto,
cómo los derechos del animal y el activismo ambiental
que nunca han herido a nadie
podrían volverse una amenaza principal para el FBI
como terrorismo nacional.
Unos años después, me invitaron a testificar
ante el Congreso sobre mi informe,
y le dije a los legisladores que mientras todos
hablan de ecología,
algunos arriesgan sus vidas
para defender bosques y detener oleoductos.
Están arriesgando físicamente sus cuerpos
entre los arpones de los balleneros y las ballenas.
Son personas comunes
como estos manifestantes en Italia
que espontáneamente treparon
cercas de alambre de púas para rescatar beagles
de la experimentación con animales.
Estos movimientos han sido sumamente eficaces
y populares,
así que en 1985 sus oponentes acuñaron una nueva palabra,
ecoterrorista,
para cambiar la forma de verlos.
Simplemente la acuñaron.
Estas empresas han apoyado nuevas leyes
como la Ley de Terrorismo Empresarial Animal,
que convierte al activismo en terrorismo
si provoca pérdidas de beneficios.
Mucha gente nunca oyó de esta ley,
inclusive los miembros del Congreso.
Menos del 1 % estaba en el recinto
cuando se aprobó en la Cámara Baja.
El resto estaban afuera en el nuevo memorial.
Estaban alabando al Dr. King
mientras su estilo de activismo era tildado de terrorismo
si se hiciera en nombre de los animales o el medio ambiente.
Los partidarios dicen que se necesitan leyes como esta
para los extremistas:
los vándalos, los incendiarios, los radicales.
Pero ahora las empresas como TransCanada
están capacitando a la policía en presentaciones como esta
sobre cómo perseguir manifestantes no violentos
como terroristas.
Los documentos de formación del FBI sobre ecoterrorismo
no son sobre violencia,
sino sobre relaciones públicas.
Hoy, en varios países,
las corporaciones están impulsando nuevas leyes
que hacen ilegal fotografiar
la crueldad animal en las granjas.
La última fue en Idaho hace 2 semanas,
y hoy lanzamos una demanda
impugnándola por ser tan inconstitucional
como amenazar al periodismo.
El primero de estos procesamientos "ag-gag",
como se los llama,
fue a una joven llamada Amy Meyer.
Amy vio que movían a una vaca enferma
hacia un matadero en un bulldozer
mientras iba por la vía pública.
Amy hizo lo que haría cualquiera de nosotros:
Lo filmó.
Cuando me enteré de su historia, escribí sobre eso,
y en 24 horas creó tal conmoción
que los fiscales retiraron todos los cargos.
Pero, aparentemente, incluso exponer cosas así
es una amenaza.
A través de la Ley de Libertad de Información,
supe que la unidad de lucha contra el terrorismo
ha estado siguiendo mis artículos
y discursos como este.
Incluso incluyeron este bonito y pequeño relato sobre mi libro.
Lo describen como "convincente y bien escrito".
(Aplausos)
Comentario de el próximo libro, ¿no?
La idea de todo esto es atemorizarnos,
pero como periodista, tengo una fe inquebrantable
en el poder de la educación.
Nuestra mejor arma es la luz del sol.
Dostoievski escribió que toda la obra del hombre
es para demostrar que es un hombre y no una tecla de piano.
Una y otra vez a lo largo de la historia,
los poderosos han usado el miedo
para silenciar la verdad y el disenso.
Es hora de asestar una nueva nota.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)